in your face republicans are looking
very very good right now sometimes
republicans they want to play it safe
think about mitt romney 2012. i'm not
going to talk about any issues that
people actually care about i'm just
going to talk about how the economy is
bad
so you know that's kind of everyone
everyone knows the economy is bad and
they don't like that and i'm going to
talk about maybe we're going to cut
taxes a little bit but i'm not going to
talk about any of the issues that are
really
driving people the cultural issues the
social issues the issues that tug on the
heartstrings a lot more than the
marginal corporate tax rate
part of the reason romney couldn't do
that by the way is because he invented
obamacare but that was one of the
weaknesses of that nomination he is the
kind of
nice
polite republican who doesn't he just
doesn't want to rock the boat he just
wants to kind of sneak into office and
that almost always fails then you've got
the in-your-face republicans you've got
the people like donald trump
who say this country's going to hell in
a handbasket you weirdos are doing all
kinds of crazy stuff and we hate it and
we're going to stop you from doing it
stop protesting the american flag stop
transiting the kids stop pushing your
weird stuff on the country build a giant
wall stop flooding the country with
foreigners because you think it's going
to give you an electoral advantage just
cut it out you people are are jerks for
doing that we're not going to let you do
it anymore so that's that's donald trump
which
which strategy has been successful
especially in recent years obviously
it's the more aggressive strategy
because republicans and americans more
broadly have had enough we know that the
libs have gone too far when we talk
about the 2024 republican nomination
a lot of people right now think the
divide is between donald trump and ron
desantis
with some other people suggesting maybe
uh senator cruz or nikki haley or mike
pompeo or mike pence some people have
suggested or whatever some other people
too
and
already people have taken really firm
sides here and they're
extremely harsh partisans for one of
those candidates over the others but the
fact remains there's a statistical fact
here donald trump is way at the top of
the heap he's up something like 40
points why is he up so high a lot of
conservatives will say why is trump
doing better than desantis
trump foisted the vaccine on us and ron
desantis stood up against
promoting the vaccine too much
trump didn't reopen the country by
easter and he gave dr fauci a lot of
power ron desantis stood up against the
kovitz stuff and that there's no
question covid is desantis's great
strength and trump's biggest weakness
here there's no question about that
and then they look on all the other
issues they say maybe here desantis is a
little more conservative well maybe here
trump is a little bit more effective and
conservative boom boom boom they go back
and forth and back and forth well look
and here's one of the greatest arguments
in favor of trump
trump got roe v wade overruled oh my
gosh it's the most important
political achievement of my lifetime
of multiple generations probably wow
that's pretty amazing okay so they're
going back and forth on the horse race
everyone is ignoring
probably the most pertinent fact
for the 2024 presidential race and it
was
demonstrated in a clip that was going
viral around the internet yesterday it
was a clip from one of trump's old
speeches mashed up with a little bit of
music just take a listen they want to
ban straws
has anybody ever tried those paper
stores they're not working
right
they want to ban straws i said well you
know i've had
a couple of
meals at mcdonald's etc over the years
wendy's friend of mine owns wendy's i'll
give it a plug right burger king
so they want to ban straws i said oh
really what about the cartons what about
the plates
what about the knives and the spoons and
the plastic
oh they're okay
[Applause]
has anybody ever tried tuesday the
district's made out of paper right
it disintegrates as you're drinking if
you have a nice guy like this guy
this would have no chance
you all hear about this what's the deal
with these paper stores
this is
trump's secret weapon and i think it
very well could be decisive in 2024 it
certainly was decisive in 2016.
trump is so
freaking entertaining he's so
funny the man is captivating he has star
quality
okay and i'm not saying that's a good
thing and i'm not saying it's a bad
thing i'm just
i'm just telling you what it is
he has that and it's why in 2016 donald
trump blew everybody else off the stage
donald trump did not have the most
conservative record in 2016 far from it
didn't matter he ended up being the most
conservative president of
my lifetime in a very very long time
but
not in 2016 he's just
he's just a magnet for attention he just
commands your attention
can ron desantis do that i don't know
maybe he can he hasn't
tried at the national level yet so maybe
he can maybe he can't that remains a big
question mark can the other candidates i
don't know maybe maybe not but what i
know is donald trump is a network tv
star and he's so freaking funny that he
could do a stand-up routine
pretty much any night of the week he
could probably go for two hours south
park made the same observation about him
in 2016 when south park was making jokes
about donald trump they always
positioned him as a kind of stand-up
comedian
when when they would depict him giving a
political speech they'd have the
spotlight come on him they'd have a
stool he'd light up a cigarette he said
you guys hear about this you guys hear
about this thing
what's the deal with my wife or whatever
so
that's really important because people
who are listening to the show are
probably very high information voters
you consume a lot of political media you
know where the candidates stand on the
issues you're focused you're hyper
vigilant on all of the the different
domestic and foreign matters most voters
are not like that
most voters are not like that not even
i'm not even trying to disparage most
voters most voters just have other
things to do they're just not focused
and it doesn't interest them that much
and so they're paying a relatively low
amount of attention to the political
scene and that guy is going to command
your attention
more so i think than most other
candidates if if a candidate wants to
beat trump in a primary you've got to
figure out a way to get over that some
of the candidates tried to do that in
2016 it didn't work marco rubio you
remember he tried to do his don rickles
routine for a while he said damn trump
is so funny how come he okay and then
rubio did that whole routine about how
trump has small hands and that implied
that he had tiny genitals and it
completely backfired i mean the guy just
stepped on a rake and trump squashed him
with it because you you can't really
fake it
you've got that star quality or you
don't you've you've you've honed that
skill or you haven't
people have to to
people have to take on that
particular strength if they want to be
trump in 2024
and trump's going to be even funnier in
2024 because the libs are providing so
much material
there's a third grade teacher just went
viral on tick tock as a queer third
grade teacher who's got crazy colored
hair and has gone off about her sexual
desires on tick tock but she says look
she doesn't make a big deal out of it
i am an openly queer teacher no i don't
stand in front of my elementary students
and be like
i like women but i wear a bi flag watch
band
buy flag bracelets
in my classroom i keep a rainbow flag
it's got mickey mouse on it because i
love mickey but it's got
a rainbow my kids know what it means
this is me telling them i am a safe
place to talk
without
making a big deal out of being queer
side note i shaved the side of my head
love it
okay going back to the main topic anyway
so because i am openly queer my students
trust me especially my queer students i
teach
fifth grade this next school year i've
been teaching fourth grade for the last
four years
anyway right now i'm teaching summer
school and i have third graders
like i said i wear these bracelets to
let them know i'm a safe space
two students two third grade students
came to me and asked me to use they them
pronouns isn't that great i i trans a
couple of my third grade students
because i don't make a big deal out of
it i don't i don't broadcast that i'm
queer
you know i mean i wear multiple
bracelets that are basically billboards
that say i'm queer and i dye my hair
like the queer thing and i got that
haircut that all the queer people got in
2013 or 2014
and i whenever students come up to me
and mention anything about sex i love to
talk to them about it and i really
indulge those conversations but i don't
make a big deal out of it right
if that's not a big deal what what would
making a big deal of it be would she
would she jump out of a cake every
morning in her and do a little
striptease in her third grade classroom
i don't know how you could make a bigger
deal yeah i've got the flag up in my
classroom
and you know i give all of my students a
dose of lupron before we start that's
for snack time i give them some
cross-sex hormones but i don't really
make a big deal out of it right
these people are beyond parody and it's
not just the conservatives who oppose
that it's the majority of americans and
republicans especially the funny ones
you're gonna have a field day with that
in 2022 and 2024.
i'm glad you like that clip now i am
very close to a million subscribers i
really want to hit a million subscribers
that's when they're going to send me my
big gold play button and i'm going to
feel like a really really cool guy until
they just nuke my channel there's no way
they're going to let me get above a
million subscribers right there's no
there's no chance
that the powers that be well who cares i
don't mind i don't mind i want to
accelerate all the way there baby if you
don't mind subscribe ring the bell get
the notifications we'll see you next
time
[Music]
you